guys think about the hug i thought it
was pretty good it felt staged a little
just because it was staged
um and i think that's all i have that i
think that's all the thoughts that i
know about it
well for me um i did make it a little
bit of a joke and try to make a little
bit and and i looked at george he wasn't
smirking
so i i hat's off he looks better than i
used to look i feel like huh
never mind sorry georgia look you all
look
great hey have you ever done that
exercise where you um
have you ever done that exercise where
you're saying man yeah yeah you bet
where you stare
at a stranger for a whole minute
no i've done that we stare at a stripper
for a whole minute
after that game too it's a good one and
they asked they ask you to leave
well because their window or are you in
the club or outside
in the club that's the old days though
yeah i also that's another thing that
i'm no longer going to ever do ever
again
no it was not a strip club did you go to
a lot of strip clubs i did
um not since i've been with kalala i've
been to maybe two or three
so both kaleila strip clubs yeah so you
don't go to strip club that's not a
thing
since you've been with me yeah oh in the
beginning yeah yeah
probably maybe i don't know i don't
remember maybe i want i don't remember i
don't even remember the last one i went
to but i just assumed
yeah i saw two stripers windexing each
other one time
don't they windex the poles no they
would text each other they went next to
each other's bodies
they were tightening up yeah yeah and
some of it to have that
that when you're on the pole to have
that
the sound right i don't go with glitter
like if they have glitter on bro i don't
like it no could you get a lap dance
it's like it's like a sign
yeah you're busting it's like they're
like you know how snow leopards
you know what slow the leopard is very
elusive yeah no
they are very illusionary they are very
elusive and they're they're barely on
the camera because they're very hard to
find
exactly but no leopards
there's no leopards i think you're
talking about the leopard seal
the [ __ ] aggressive aggressive with
big teeth
oh it's never let's know that leprosy
yeah yeah the limbs fall out in
minnesota
you're not talking about this that's
what i'm talking about yeah exactly i
was losing my mind man
so snow leopards will not see another
snow leopard probably their whole life
wow that's how rare they are but they
communicate each other do you know how
they communicate brah
yes they how make different sounds no
[ __ ] no do you think another snow
leopard's like right around the corner
but they don't see each other
i know johnny is right behind that
[ __ ] boulder but i ain't going to see
him so i'm going to go
what the [ __ ] are you talking about man
me
dude you're the one who is
institutionalized
we're trying to teach you about leprosy
bro
me and freaking two by face are trying
to teach you about leprosy bro
young man dude thank you phil yeah no
but a little leper
um very handsome man i think you could
be a mayor probably in some cities
different towns
but it's an island not another island
yeah definitely there's a lot of water
around the mayor but yeah
i don't know if you're a landlocked
leader
i think you can easily
run an island i appreciate that yeah man
but well snow leopards
the way the community is a snow leopard
are we saying
leper or leopard the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
phone cat the cat
the cat the white cat [ __ ] it let's move
on from it then man i don't want to know
now
you're a snow leopard bobby isn't he yes
he pees outdoors
yep and he and you'll never see anyone
else like him
ah so uh how do you communicate with
johnny around the block then
you're the snow leopard right yeah so if
i was a snake
communication rare signals
hieroglyphs made of urine yeah
now now i'll tell you what's happening
now guys now i don't even know why the
[ __ ] i wasn't even thinking
you're saying that they never they they
in their whole lifetime they barely come
across and that's exactly
what i was saying and how they
communicate is they rub their sh they
rub their bodies on a tree
oh right so then a year later another
like their mother
will smell that tree and go oh johnny's
still alive that's cool
and then she'll rub and that's how
that's that's her cell phone
damn they don't have texting you know
it's more of a nokia yeah
yeah yeah where you can only do one
thing it's like a t-mobile sidekick
yeah yeah i never got one of those you
didn't
i was that was i was too poor to get
that they were i had one somebody give
it to me as a gift one time it was okay
it was big though big in your pocket do
you remember the first nokia had that
one game
snake yes oh i love it and then when you
play snake you're like
i'm in the future yeah like you thought
it was the most technological thing
you've ever seen
this is future [ __ ] right yeah i'm
trying to think of what it
was it's snake was the best thing that
was a great it's basically what it was
oh yeah so you're you had to catch
little um things without eating your own
tail
so you couldn't touch your own tail
that's what it was and the tail would
you get longer right yeah so the
tailgate would get harder
you would have to escape contact from
your tail but still be able to
um it was it like a little pac-man thing
that you would have
and it would add on to his body each
time yeah my it got so bad my sponsor
was like you can't play snake no more
yeah that's what it was
look i thought that was the future i'm a
blade runner wow
yeah yeah but now you know [ __ ]
what you can do all kinds of [ __ ] with
video games yeah right